thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we're glad you're
here open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five Debra's with
us in San Diego hi Debra how are you
hello thank you for taking my call sure
I really enjoyed that last segment on
the Sabbath and resting that was a great
second segment I got a lot out of that
I'm also interested in your seven baby
step program but the reason for my call
is what time a plan does a person that
has $200,000 plus and student loans that
are in deferment Wow a mortgage that's
twenty-five hundred and twenty five
hundred dollars a month three hundred
dollars car payment and making around
ninety thousand dollars a year so what
are you on the car but probably sixteen
thousand well you've got several things
that are out of whack as you know who's
got two hundred thousand you you have
personally have two thousand one dinner
you and your husband together know
myself as a long story we have two sons
that have graduated and the youngest
just graduated so in six months the
those loans are going to you know become
do but I'm gonna have to put them in the
firm until I can figure out you know how
my Zdenek because the the payment on the
thing is twenty five hundred dollars or
something like that
it's these are pant PLUS loans jority of
them are okay yeah and it's a
combination of two sons okay well here's
the thing you look at it's you know
sadly it is simple math and the math
that I always use when I'm here on the
air talking to someone about their debt
you know you always hear me ask okay
will you make and how much is a debt and
that that ratio is what I call the
shovel to hole ratio so you're in a two
hundred thousand dollar hole plus your
car right and yeah and your shovel is
ninety thousand
okay so if you told me your if you told
me your shovel was two hundred ninety
thousand it'd be a different way of
looking at it right but if you're
talking if you told me your debt was
only ninety thousand and you were making
nine thousand it'd be a different ratio
the shovel to hole ratio so what this
tells me is what you already know is
your budget is unbelievably tight your
house payment is too big a percentage of
your take-home pay already add to that
this Parent PLUS disaster add to that a
car payment that you can't afford yeah
you got you got big-time cash flow
problems and so you know it's not going
to be like you're gonna be out of debt
anytime soon with that kind of ratio so
something is going to give here and you
probably should decide what's going to
give instead of somebody deciding for
you by starting to take stuff from your
life so what is your home worth probably
about four four thirty I guess maybe
what do you if we just bought this I've
only been in here a year where did y'all
on it for 27 for 25 something like that
and that's not an expensive home in San
Diego no it's not we live outside of San
Diego it's a below average home but
$2,500 as a percentage of your take-home
pay is about every dime you could have
you could qualify for so is there any
chance your incomes are going up
well yeah but you know the way the
raises are these days with these
companies you know little or nothing is
less than five or so it's not like
you're on some kind of fast track to
double your income or something no no
it'll it'll increase but not known if it
can't enough to yeah and what are you
all on your car the car sixteen thousand
you got a high interest rate on that
then that's about yeah five point nine I
think it is
you can't pay pay you can't pay payments
on all three of these things and eat
that's our problem
yeah well the student loan is what's
gonna kill me because no I mean and you
and yet you signed up for it well yeah I
did but I thought at that point that it
would be it could be arranged that I you
know according to what I'm my regular
income and my outgoing put this on an
income based payment plan it won't even
pay the interest on this you'll be in
debt the rest of your life yeah that's
not gonna work so something's got to
give here what does that mean I have to
lose my house I don't know if you're
gonna lose it but you're not going to be
able to pay it and you're not gonna be
able pay that and a car payment and a
student loan payment and be out of debt
in this century so mathematically and
I'm not picking on you I'm just telling
you what you already knew that this is a
dire situation so I think you're gonna
have to move way down in house you may
have to move areas of the country I
don't know because I don't think you've
bought some kind of opulent structure
outside of San Diego for fifty thousand
dollars is not a huge house no you
bought modestly in terms of the actual
lifestyle but the math is not modest
that's the problem and so what do you
guys do for a living
I'm an IT what do you do you know I'm
system analyst okay troubleshoot our
systems are you single uh well no now I
was divor I got divorced and now I'm
remarried okay what is her husband like
he doesn't make much he he's a he does
he works in shops in like sheet metal
which is a good industry but he got laid
and now he's doing retail until he can
get back into a shop okay so he gets
back into the shop his incomes gonna go
way up over and what we're talking about
is the ninety thousand you alone yeah
okay so when he's in a shop in he making
seventy probably maybe forty to fifty I
think yeah with overtime seventy and he
needs some overtime yeah because you
guys are broke now yeah I put seventy
thousand on top of this now I got a
hundred and sixty thousand dollar income
and you pick up some side gigs in the IT
world and add another ten or twenty to
this you're very marketable in the IT
world if you know what you're doing for
all kinds of remote work and side stuff
contract stuff on the side while you're
doing your full-time thing you guys you
know income it if we can add 60 $70,000
$80,000 to your household income now we
got something to work with and get the
car sold and you start plowing through
the student loan in three years then and
then you get your life back after that
but you paying this by yourself on 90
grand is not gonna happen
math the math is there now I would keep
my house and both of you go work like
crazy people and let's create another
eighty thousand dollars for the income
between overtime him getting back into a
sheet metal shop and taking all the OT
he can get you picking up all the
contract work on the side you can do
anything you can do remote or whatever I
don't care what it is you know the tech
world and you're in a tech corridor so
you should be able to land some stuff
and you've got to create some income or
you need to sell your home in your car
and move to an inexpensive area to live
in that's not the San Diego market and
start trying to work your way out of
this ridiculous mess you've made with
the two hundred thousand dollars worth
of income our twenty thousand dollars
worth a Parent PLUS loans and you've got
to quit buying things like cars and
Parent PLUS loans and houses that don't
fit the math of your life because it
takes your life away that's your problem
so hold on Debra I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover to help you guys work through
this process but the best answer to your
mess is
huge amounts of new income with him
getting a better job him putting all of
that in the on the table to solve these
problems who's selling your car and get
you a cheap beater car and then let's
let's work our way through this thing
and maybe these boys that graduate can
actually throw some money in this you
know cuz it's not like her mom could
afford to pay for their education she's
broke something to think about this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]